All right, let's go back to the phones and
see what's on folks' minds.
Let's go to our caller from the nine five
two area code.
Who's calling today from nine five two.
Hello?
Hello.
Yes, I can.
Hey, David.
Mike.
Uh, so my question was, um, so given all of
the sort of recent events that have occurred
in the news cycle, such as like the whistleblower
complaint against Donald Trump, sure.
All of the individuals that are implicated
and ms complaints such as my con PEO and William
Barr in the fact that there's even a coverup,
um, what's associated with some of the calls
that Trump has made, um, Trump still seems
to maintain and about a 40% approval rating.
I mean, what do you think the reason is that
people still will ardently defend them?
And what do you think it would take for voters
that are supportive of his to finally flip?
I don't think that, so here's the thing, he
has a floor of support.
I don't know if it's like 27 or 26 or 32 or
something like that, who will never flip.
It doesn't matter.
What he does is he has said if you shot someone
on fifth Avenue, they still wouldn't flip.
You can then add to that Republicans who just
really hate Democrats and are just going to
say they approve of the job that Donald Trump
is doing.
So you're going to have that group and then
you've got people who are just not super keyed
in and they lack information about what's
going on.
And it's just sort of like, yeah, I guess
my life's not bad.
So I guess I, I guess I approve.
And that's how you get yourself to 40% with
a president that is this embroiled in scandal
and potential criminality and immorality that
that's how it's constructed.
Right.
It almost seems like unprecedented own sense
that, um, it doesn't seem like any other candidate
has enjoyed the kind of support or the kind
of base that come pass.
Like it's almost like a religious sort of
fervor that his base has for him.
Like what do you think that is?
Like, what do you think that comes from?
I, you know, I think that it's a key, I don't
know that it's that unique maybe to this degree,
but it's like George W. Bush approval rating
did go very low at one point, but he had a
base and then it recovered very quickly.
Barack Obama's approval network never went
below a certain level and we don't, it wasn't
tested whether he had an unflinching base.
So I don't know that it's that unique in the
hyperpartisan 2019 but there's definitely
people who are just, they love Trump.
That's it.
Yeah.
I guess what I'm trying to get at too is,
I mean there's so much clearly wrong with
Trump and there's so, so much manifestly just
disorganized in his mind and like he just
seems like a very unwell person.
Yes.
The very least you could say, George W. Bush
hasn't been near of being an S, at least in
normal human beings functioning.
Right.
But you can't really say the same with Donald
Trump.
It just seems very odd that people can love
someone that's so clearly just a diluted narcissist.
It just doesn't make sense.
I completely agree with you and you know what
I would suggest is go talk to some of those
people who support them and listen to the
answers they give you, and you'll very quickly
understand what's going on.
Right.
You know, funny you say that because my grandfather
is a big Trump supporter.
Bring it up.
Just don't even in family situations to make
things awkward.
But I get it sort of like there's a cynicism
in his support, right, that everything is
just so bad and at least Trump is honest about
everything being so bad.
If that makes any sense.
Like there's almost like an emotional connection
to that sort of hate for the establishment
and I think like sort of mainstream.
Yeah, it's like the right word.
Right.
There's definitely the idea of Trump as the
guy who's trolling people and, and some contingent
of his likes that, and that's also extraordinarily
disturbing.
Right.
And sorry if I'm taking up too much time,
but just one last statement I think too is
that there's like the sort of like older generation
sort of sees like the young up and coming
Democrats.
It's sort of like a threat and sort of almost
seems like in a sense like a dying gas generation
kind of trying to cling on to power and, and
keep things as the way they were.
That's interesting.
That may be, but we won't know for like another
15 years.
Right.
Alright.
Well thank you so much.
I appreciate your time.
Okay, thanks.
I appreciate the phone call.
Great to hear from you.